The Cherry Tree Shopping Center in Scaggsville has a new tenant.
Kelsey's Kloset offers secondhand designer clothes, accessories and handbags.
People can bring their goods in to sell them for cash...
...or come to shop for them at discount prices.
The store started with Kelsey and her sisters' own gently used clothes...
...and has grown in the nearly two months it's been open.
The store is open seven days a week...
...and there's a learning curve to running a small business, of course,...
...but Kelsey is picking it up quickly because it's something she's passionate about.
It's really hard, you live and you learn.
So, as you make mistakes, you just get right back up and keep trying.
Kelsey graduated at the age of 16 from an online high school...
...in order to free herself up to start pursuing her dreams.
She encourages any other young entrepreneur to do the same.
I hope to open another Kelsey's Kloset somewhere in the future.